how to find customers abroad so I got a
great question fun of my youtube viewers
love you guys send who wrote in the say
hi Evan thanks for the very informative
video I'm sent from Sri Lanka and I want
to start a travel agent business with a
website based but I have no idea how to
find customers abroad I'm new to tour
operating I have no idea how to tour
operating model works through a website
as well can you help me appreciate it
cheers send thank you for the great
question and in all honesty if you have
no idea how model works the best thing I
can advise you to do is go out and work
for somebody who's doing it take three
months six months a year whatever it is
and go model success you'll learn all
the mistakes that you would have made
you get to make on somebody else's dime
while they're paying you do it you learn
how to industry works you'll learn how
to get customers you learn what trips
really sell you learn so much more by
working with that competent and trying
to figure it out all your own and your
your runway lasts a lot longer because
now you're not dipping into your savings
to make this thing work you're getting
paid to learn how to do it and when you
launch will be a lot more successful so
it would be my first kind of quick intro
bit of advice whenever you have no idea
how something works go find someone
who's already doing exactly what you're
doing and go work with them for a little
bit and this is not like I get a job and
now I'm stuck in this thing for us in my
life three months six months whatever it
takes just so you learn when you feel
like you're learning isn't happening
anymore you've capped out you know
you've peaked is it more momentum that's
when you you you leap when you start
your own business or you go find
something else okay but I want to give
you three bits of advice to help you
grow this business to get your clients
internationally from a bra to care about
what you're doing the first is stand for
something you need to stand for
something with your business why do I
care about you what's so special about
you there's tons of tour operators
there's tons of places for me as someone
from north america i can go to where I
can go anywhere in the world my vacation
why am i coming to Sri Lanka you gotta
you gotta convince me that you are doing
something important right so you have to
find what is in you what's your one war
what's driving this that makes you want
to create this business so if you stood
for adventure say you know you think the
world needs more adventure then you lead
with you know yala national park or if
you are trying to get a sense of calm
you believe that people you'll need more
common to relax and to be stress free
then maybe you're showing adam's peak
but why is your business here right
because it was just to make money i
don't care that i'm going to when I'm
doing my research as if somebody from
North America who might be a customer
I'm just going to try to find the
cheapest place and that's what you're
competing on its price if you want to
stand out and not just compete on price
and you have to stand for something and
make me feel connected to your business
somehow and show me that you're doing
this not just to make money but to make
the world a better place how are you
going to do that that's what I want to
know so number one stand for something
number two is connect with online and
offline media what i would do is now
that you know what you're standing for
you've created a great website around it
that when i come to your site i feel
something i would start connecting with
traditional media and online media
bloggers youtube video people like me
people who are big on twitter who all
believe in the same thing right so if
it's adventure and you've got yellow
national park and you believe the world
needs more adventure start reaching out
to travel bloggers who talk about
adventure who people on social media
creating YouTube videos about adventure
and let them know about all the great
things that you're doing and show them
your website because if I love adventure
right if I feel adventure in my bones
and I come to your website which now
stands for adventure I should be like
wow this is amazing right I believe in
entrepreneurs so if you showed me a
website that was all about believing in
entrepreneurs I'm going to tweet about
it I'm going to make a video but I'm
gonna share it because I staying for the
same thing so it's connecting with
people who have influence in the market
that you're trying to reach in this case
North America or abroad who believe in
the same thing that you're trying to
accomplish reach out to them and they'll
help you spread your message and number
three is form alliances so beyond just
the media beyond just having people
share your link and say hey check these
guys out ideal you can also get somebody
in low
markets who can help sell your stuff for
you who understand the culture who can
speak the language who who can relate to
the customers when I had my first
software company that one of the first
things I did was I got international
distributors people the south for me and
I would funnel actually leads to them
and they would develop their own
customers as well because I don't know
how to speak to somebody in Japan
properly right I can't speak Japanese I
don't understand the culture I don't
understand the the rituals the timezone
difference is ridiculous so I'd rather
have somebody in Japan representing me
who loves my brand and who can represent
me well out there selling to his local
market so find and form alliances with
local people who again staying for the
same thing you do and who can present it
in that same voice that you're creating
because those people understand the
culture and can better sell to that
local market so remember if you're
trying to get more customers abroad
number one stand for something number to
connect with online offline media number
three form alliances and believe for
those you're watching like a video you
can subscribe to the channel to see more
just like this thank you so much I'll
see you soon